يعاني ملايين الأشخاص من
ذروة ما تسميه خدمة الطقس حدثًا واحدًا
في كل جيل
لا يزال الآخرون يستعدون
[موسيقى]
انفجار القطب الشمالي الذي أثر على أكثر من 105
مليون شخص في جميع أنحاء البلاد
تنبيهات الشتاء من الساحل إلى الساحل
للثلوج والظروف الجليدية
البرد الخطير لديه أكثر من 150 مليون شخص أو
ما يقرب من نصف سكان الولايات المتحدة تحت
تنبيهات برد الرياح مع قشعريرة رياح أقل من الصفر في
أقصى الجنوب مثل تكساس
في الغرب الأوسط أكثر من قدم واحدة من الثلج
وظروف عاصفة ثلجية محتملة من
المتوقع أن يكون Sioux
Falls Frozen الشهير
في ساوث داكوتا  من كانساس ،
أبلغت خدمة الأرصاد الجوية الوطنية عن قشعريرة رياح
أقل من 30 سالب. ومن
المتوقع أن يظل البرد هناك وفي السهول في
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع لعيد الميلاد ، مما
يجعله أبرد عيد الميلاد هناك منذ ما يقرب من
40 عامًا ، حيث يتجمد شعر أنفك حرفيًا
حتى تلك التي اعتادت على البرد في
تشعر وايومنغ بانفجار القطب الشمالي ،
أعني أن الجو بارد ولكن عندما يكون سالب 20
يكون مجرد مستوى آخر
تجعل ظروف القيادة والثلوج خطيرة
المركبات المهجورة التي تقطعت بها السبل السائقين الذين تقطعت بهم السبل ،
أريد أن يكون لدى الناس أشياء في
سياراتهم ، وأطفالهم جاهزون للنشر إذا
علقوا في سيارتهم في
مكان ما ، وتسبب مخاطر الطقس
في إغلاق الطرق في أجزاء مختلفة من البلاد ،
مما يجعل من الصعب عليهم
يستجيب عمال الطوارئ هناك
بعض الجوارب لتدفئة
اليدين مثل بعض منتجات النظافة
ثم بعض الماء والبطانية في
كولورادو.
إنها
حالة طوارئ قصوى حقيقية حيث سيكونون حقًا على حق
في حافلات الأشخاص الذين يبحثون عن مأوى
في دنفر كوليسيوم للبقاء بعيدًا عن
البرد القارس